[Musik]
der Polarkreis ist erreicht eine Kelle 1
landet im Nacken der Passagiere eine
Tradition auf den Schiffen der rote
groten
das macht den Gästen Spaß und mir auch
die Fahrt mit den Postschiffen entlang
der norwegischen Küste ist für die
Reisenden ein echtes Erlebnis
ein Höhepunkt jeder Reise die
Nordlichter das Himmelsschauspiel
begeistert jedes Jahr tausende
postschiffreisende
Henni Schäfer und Cedric auf der Suche
nach ihrer Familie den beiden Körnern
wurde nach dem Einchecken Kabine 26
zugewiesen doch die ist gar nicht so
einfach zu finden
[Musik]
ein Blick auf den schiffsplan sorgt für
Orientierung schließlich ist die
richtige Kabine gefunden ihre
Ausstattung sorgt bei Rene aber für eine
Überraschung
hallo und dann muss man das hier so
umklappen
sehr gut da kannst du kein Platz von mir
wegnehmen
ich habe bin froh dass ich mir eine
eigene Decke habe ich
bin Prinzessin
ein Zustand der sich in den nächsten
zwei Wochen nicht ändern wird
zwei Decks höher ist auch Familie Koal
auf dem Weg zu ihrer Kabine zu viert
brauchen aukje Dominik Tochter Livia und
Sohn DAX natürlich ein etwas größeres
Zimmer wow viel Platz
für die Familie ist es die erste größere
Reise zu viert und da kann bei der
Planung schon mal etwas schief gehen
wo ist das Kinderbett ich weiß nicht ob
hier irgendein geheimer Gang
ein zusätzliches Schlafsofa hat die
Kabine zwar aber darauf kann so ein
Dachs nicht schlafen
wir haben auch vorher keine Bilder oder
sonst was gesehen oder haben uns
irgendwie gar nicht vorher informiert
sondern haben einfach unsere überraschen
lassen
um diese Überraschung wird sich Dominik
zusammen mit der schiffs-
denn die nächsten sechs Tage werden sie
mit dem Schiff die norwegische Küste
entlangfahren die Reise beginnt in
Bergen dem südlichsten Punkt der Route
hier startet täglich ein Schiff Richtung
Norden 33 Häfen werden unterwegs
angelaufen Endstation ist Kirkenes im
äußersten Nordosten Norwegens unweit der
russischen Grenze
der erste morgen an Bord Hanni und
Cedric haben die Nacht in ihren
Einzelbetten unterschiedlich erlebt ich
bin in der Nacht aber ein bisschen
aufgewacht immer mal wieder
weil ich so ein bisschen Angst hatte
und dann denken unsere was passiert wenn
das Schiff jetzt umkippt oder aber das
passiert natürlich nicht das weiß ich
auch das war auf jeden Fall spannend
angenehm also für mich war es irgendwann
so ein bisschen so ein Schlaf schaukeln
so dann kam zwischendurch da so eine
kleine Bemerkung von rechts oh mein Gott
oh mein Gott aber das war dann auf jeden
Fall ganz okay
jetzt geht's erstmal zum Frühstück bevor
in zwei Stunden der erste Hafen erreicht
wird
schon früh am Morgen ist
expeditionsleiterin Svenja Nordmann
zwischen den verschiedenen Decks
unterwegs ja man muss immer gucken dass
man sich bewegt im Arbeitsalltag war für
mich ist Aufzug grundsätzlich tabu
denn sonst sitzt man an manchen Tagen zu
viel so ist es gelegentlich aber
zugegebenermaßen ich muss eine Minute
warten bis ich deine Durchsage mache und
erstmal Luft schnappen
an Bord der Rickert Wied sind rund 300
Passagiere viele sind Touristen die
Norwegens faszinierende
fjord-landschaften erleben wollen
alle Ausflüge auf der Reise organisiert
Svenja mit ihrem Team
komm meistens um 8 Uhr momentan hoch und
dann ist also oft schon der erste
Ausflug dran im Sommer zum Beispiel
haben wir unseren ersten Ausflug um
Viertel vor 6 Uhr morgens dann muss ich
natürlich dann dementsprechend um 5:30
Uhr in der Arbeit sein
seit zehn Jahren lebt und arbeitet die
gebürtige Münchnerin jetzt in Norwegen
der Job an Bord ist nicht gerade
familienfreundlich der Rhythmus aus drei
Wochen Arbeit drei Wochen Freizeit hat
vor und Nachteile
gegen 12 Uhr läuft das Schiff in
orlesund ein mit über 53.000 Einwohnern
eine der größeren Städte entlang der
Küste 10 Stunden dauert der Aufenthalt
Zeit die Hänge und Cedric für einen
Landgang nutzen neben der
Stadtbesichtigung möchte die Studentin
für Modejournalismus auch Fotos für
Ihren Internetauftritt machen
wenn das besser ist
Content Produktion für ihre Follower auf
Instagram veröffentlicht Handy
regelmäßig Fotos und Videos sie hat da
genaue Vorstellungen die Bilder von
Freund Cedric stellen sie aber nicht
immer gleich zufrieden
geht das auch so Fotos gehst du auch
strategisch an weil wenn zum Beispiel
ich sage okay ich hätte gerne irgendwie
so eine Art Bild dann sagt er okay und
dann so wir Mädels würden dann
vielleicht irgendwie uns erstmal
hinstellen und Fotos machen und Handy
sagt so okay warte wir berechnen das
ganze und nehmen das aus diesem Winkel
neben diesen Arsch
da kannst
das Handy abgegeben
diese Fotos sind Cedric gelungen
das poste ich jetzt direkt das ist quasi
mein Look für heute und
auf Instagram Folgen der 24-Jährigen
bereits rund 18.000 Menschen vor drei
Jahren hat sie angefangen über
Modetrends und ihre Reisen zu berichten
als Besonderheit wollen die beiden
olles und heute vom Wasser aus
besichtigen gespannt auf jeden Fall ja
[Musik]
statt mit dem Bus auf Stadtrundfahrt zu
gehen haben sich die beiden für eine
Kajak-Tour entschieden das schmale Boot
durch die Kanäle zu steuern ist aber gar
nicht so einfach
mit dem Körper drehen
das mal nach da
handy geht nicht
nach Startschwierigkeiten haben die
beiden den Dreh dann aber schnell raus
nur auf Tempo und Fahrtrichtung müssen
sie sich noch einigen
na das Problem ist dass Cedric dann auch
immer dazu neigt ein bisschen provokant
zu sein das treibt einen manchmal so ein
bisschen zur Weißglut
es kann passieren
wirklich wunderschön auch die Häuser
vom Wasser aus zeigt sich die Stadt von
ihrer schönsten Seite alle Sund ist auf
mehreren Inseln gebaut
1904 war die Stadt nach einem Großbrand
total zerstört und wurde mit deutscher
Hilfe in der damaligen Architektur des
Jugendstils wieder aufgebaut
nicht alle Passagiere der Rickert weht
konnten die Liegezeit für einen Ausflug
in die Stadt nutzen auch hier Qual ist
mit ihren Kindern an Bord geblieben die
erste Etappe von Bergen hierher hat
Spuren bei der Familie hinterlassen
ich war ein bisschen mit Krankheit
leider also ein bisschen sehr Krankheit
war im Spiel aber mein Mann Dominik und
der kleine die haben ja sicher bisschen
über Game und das Wichtigste ist dass
man Ruhe überhaupt
wenn diese Moment denkt man sich oh Gott
wir sind jetzt auf Tag 1 und hat sich
das ein bisschen anders vorgestellt für
die vierköpfige Familie ist es die erste
Schiffsreise das einer von ihnen
seekrank werden könnte damit haben sie
nicht gerechnet der urlaubsstatus etwas
getrübt besonders bei Vater Dominik
hallo
wie geht's dir
geguckt ob ich wie die Flüge wie viele
Flüge Kosten nach Hause
ja wirklich also ich habe wirklich
verzweifelt oder nicht gedacht scheiße
das schaffst du auf jeden Fall nicht
weiter also wenn es wirklich jetzt
weitergeht keine Ahnung aber morgens ist
man aufgestanden guckt aus dem Fenster
und sieht einfach wie schön es ist
einfach ist es äh hatte alles man hatte
wieder alles vergessen was in der Nacht
passiert ist
dass wir hier bleiben
den Rest des Tages werden sie in ihrer
Kabine verbringen auch hier hofft dass
die Reisetabletten wirken und die
Norwegische See und Dominiks Magen in
den nächsten Tagen ruhig bleiben
bevor das Schiff in der Nacht wieder in
See sticht hat Svenja Nordmann vom
Expeditionsteam noch einiges zu tun
wir haben solche Tage wo wir aus für
sehr früh morgens so schicken müssen
oder das mitternachtskonzert sehr spät
abends und an solchen Tagen ergibt sich
dann manchmal dass man drei Mal an Land
springen
31 Passagiere haben sich für einen
nächtlichen Ausflug angemeldet Svenja
muss dafür sorgen dass alle Teilnehmer
das Schiff verlassen und pünktlich
wieder da sind der Bus mit dem es vom
Hafen aus weitergeht wartet schon
es ist manchmal sehr hektisch ja vor
allem wenn man ein bisschen zu spät sind
das ist in Ordnung ja danke schön
20 Engländer okay dann sehen
bei dem straffen Zeitplan ist gute
Organisation entscheidend
[Musik]
der zweite Tag auf sie die norwegische
Küste zeigt sich von ihrer schönsten
Seite das Licht in den Morgenstunden
kurz vor der Dämmerung taucht die
Landschaft in eine ganz besondere
Atmosphäre für die Reise von Bergen nach
Kirkenes zahlen die Passagiere zwischen
2000 und 8000 Euro pro Person je nach
Größe und Ausstattung ihrer Kabine
die Schiffe der rote groten
transportieren aber nicht nur Touristen
in den Frachträumen werden auch waren
zwischen den Häfen befördert und viele
Norweger nutzen die post-linie als
Verkehrsmittel dass die Küstenorte
miteinander verbindet
in jedem Hafen steigen Passagiere ein
und aus
und so mancher Einheimische wie hier in
Hammerfest nutzt den Stopp des Schiffes
als kleine Abwechslung
[Musik]
man kann unsere Stadt von einer anderen
Seite sehen von mehr aus es gibt hier
auch gutes Essen und Kaffee wir kommen
gerne hierher
die rote groten gehören für viele
Norweger zur Tradition ihres Landes dass
die Postschiffe nicht mehr nur
Transportmittel sind ärgert manche
es ist schon enttäuschend dass der Fokus
so auf den Touristen legt für uns
Einheimische ist es nicht mehr dasselbe
es ist schwierig einen Platz an Bord zu
kriegen und es ist teuer
die Schiffsroute entlang der Küste ist
eine Lebensader für das Land
1893 fährt Kapitän Rickert Wied als
erster die Strecke zwischen den
Handelszentren im Süden und den
Fischerdörfern im Norden die Schiffe
transportierten Post und Güter und
wurden für immer mehr Norweger zur
schnellen Fährverbindung heute sind die
Einnahmen aus dem Tourismus für die
Schifffahrtslinie wichtiger als das
Frachtgeschäft
[Musik]
Sicherheitsübungen gehören zum Alltag
der Crews denn das Wetter im
europäischen Nordmeer kann schnell mal
umschlagen und die sie sehr stürmisch
werden regelmäßige Checks der
schwindesten und der Rettungsbote dienen
dazu dass man für Notfälle gerüstet ist
[Musik]
passen 150 Menschen jeder schwarze Punkt
ist ein Platz
die Teilnahme an solchen
Sicherheitsübungen ist für die
Passagiere keine Pflicht
Henni macht aber gerne mit sie ist nicht
gerade die mutigste und die Übung hilft
dir
bleibt
hier ist ein Licht das leuchtet wenn du
im Wasser bist
okay kommt an Bord aber Vorsicht ist es
rutschig meine Evakuierung würde ein
Crewmitglied hier stehen und zählen bis
150 Menschen an Bord sind
im Ernstfall wird es also eng im
Rettungsboot das hilft gegen die Kälte
und natürlich Bewegung
wenn der Motor ausfällt wird gerudert
laut das ist aber sehr anstrengend
und wer muss dein Bruder du
also ich sag was interessant zu wissen
auch dass noch 100 gibt und nicht nur
Motoren für die beiden Studenten sorgt
die Aktion also nicht nur für
Abwechslung an Bord sondern gibt Ihnen
auch ein gutes Gefühl also wenn ich mir
das jetzt gerade vorstelle dann ist es
schon eine einerseits beängstigende
Vorstellung es ist alles laut man hat
irgendwie Angst ist auch gerade kalt ich
finde das macht auch was aus auf der
anderen Seite habe ich das Gefühl dass
es hier schon relativ gut unter
Kontrolle
eine Kreuzfahrt im herkömmlichen Sinne
ist die Reise mit dem Postschiff nicht
es gibt keine Animation keine Disco kein
Casino
hauptattraktion ist die langsam
vorbeigleitende Küstenlandschaft die
Stille der Natur scheint sich auf die
Reisenden zu übertragen
in der Kabine von Familie kual geht es
etwas lebhafter zu auch Vater dominik
ist wieder fit aber ganz genießen kann
die Familie ihre Schiffsreise noch nicht
gestern zum Beispiel mussten wir den
wach machen
dementsprechend
also haben wir abends dann beim Essen
halt richtig Probleme
damit alle Passagiere einen Platz finden
gibt es festgelegte Zeiten für die Gäste
im Schiffsrestaurant eine Stunde muss
zum Essen reichen nicht gerade gemütlich
Penny und Cedric haben ihren Platz von
20 bis 21 Uhr zum Abendessen gibt es
drei Gerichte zur Auswahl
ich glaube dass ich mich auch zum
Beispiel gesünder ernähre als es sich
machen würde wenn jetzt hier zum
Beispiel so ein Befehl wäre wie man zum
anderen Hotels kennt da gibt's dann ja
immer so eine Pizza Theke und Pommes
oder so in der Küche ist immer Betrieb
nichts kommt aus der Dose jeden Tag wird
frisch gekocht besonders Fisch wird viel
und in allen Varianten angeboten unter
der Regie von Küchenchef Janne Matthias
Arbeiten zehn Köche gleichzeitig
wir machen jeden Tag essen für 350
Menschen inklusive der Crew da sind
ständig viele Bälle in der Luft und als
Koch musst du echt an alles denken
[Musik]
immer gegen die Zeit jede Mahlzeit muss
pünktlich fertig sein sonst haben die
Gäste nicht zu essen und dann ist
niemand glücklich
wie alle an Bord arbeitet auch Chefkoch
Janne Matthias drei Wochen am Stück
einen Job an Land hat er ausprobiert
doch das war nichts für ihn
ich habe als Praktikant angefangen und
mich hochgearbeitet zum Chefkoch
zwischendurch habe ich auch immer mal an
Land gearbeitet aber es zieht mich doch
wieder zurück an Bord
seine Gerichte schmecken den meisten
Passagieren auch wenn Handy bei Ihrer
Bestellung etwas anderes erwartet hat
im Menü stand dann Feldsalat und das ist
der Feld
zum Essen bleiben die beiden Studenten
bei Wasser denn ein Glas Wein kostet 16
Euro in Norwegen ganz normal
der dritte morgen auf See die Hälfte der
rund 2500 Kilometer langen Seereise hat
das Schiff bereits hinter sich
und erreicht ein Highlight der Reise den
Polarkreis nördlich des Polarkreises
beginnt im Winter die Phase der
kompletten Dunkelheit und im Sommer geht
die Mitternachtssonne 24 Stunden lang
nicht unter die Überquerung des
Polarkreises ist an Bord der Schiffe
jedes Mal ein besonderes Ereignis um
euch ein bisschen wach zu kriegen und
vor allem warm
zu machen wollt
die Temperatur liegt unter dem
Gefrierpunkt jetzt noch einmal aufwärmen
macht Sinn denn auf die Passagiere
wartet eine eiskalte Überraschung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jede Polarkreis Überquerung der zünftig
gefeiert zuvor allerdings muss Mord der
Schutzgott der Seefahrer und Fischer
gerufen werden um im Kampf gegen Wind
und Sturm sicheres Geleit für die
Weiterfahrt zu gewähren ein Mitglied der
Kuh schlüpft in diese Rolle um den
Moment zu zelebrieren
[Musik]
getauft wird aber nicht mit ein paar
Spritzern Wasser sondern mit einer
großen Kelle Eiswürfel direkt in den
Nacken da braucht es schon ein wenig
Überwindung
[Musik]
ja
gemischt aber nein das wird bestimmt
lustig
auch Kapitän Jensen lässt sich die Taufe
nicht entgehen
okay setz dich Henni und Cedric sind die
nächsten bei Temperaturen um 0° bleibt
einem da schon mal die Luft weg
auch hier und Dominik schauen dem
eiskalten Spaß noch ein wenig skeptisch
zu doch schließlich rein auch sie sich
in den Reigen der mutigen ein
einmaliges Erlebnis das zum Schluss mit
einem norwegischen Kräuterschnaps
begossen wird
mit knapp 30 Kilometern pro Stunde
gleitet die Ricard Wied weiter Richtung
Norden auf der Brücke hat Kapitän
Raimund Jensen das Kommando die Fahrt
entlang der norwegischen Küste erfordert
Konzentration und Erfahrung
es kann schwierig sein wegen der
Wetterbedingungen wenn wir an der Küste
sind und die Schiffe anlegen wegen
starker Winde
See dazu
aber wenn es zustürmisch wird dann
überspringen wir den Hafen einfach
sicherheit geht vor
seit rund 20 Jahren arbeitet Raimund
Jensen auf den Postschiffe für ihn und
seine Crew ist die historische Route der
beste Arbeitsplatz der Welt
ich habe es immer geliebt am Wasser zu
sein und zu fischen es ist diese
Freiheit und Aussicht
ein tolles Büro
das Navigieren dicht an der norwegischen
Küste ist oft schwieriger als auf
offener See und auch die Hafen
Einfahrten sind nicht ohne
Herausforderung 2013 wurde die Richard
wiede im Hafen von Trondheim von einer
starken Windböe gegen die Kaimauer
gedrückt und schwer beschädigt
das Wetter ändert sich hier schnell im
Vergleich zu Kreuzfahrtschiffen müssen
wir viel Wissen über die Häfen die
Strömungen und Winde
[Musik]
die Aussichten für die nächsten Tage
versprechen aber keine besonderen
Vorkommnisse
[Musik]
ein neuer Morgen an Bord damit die Tage
nicht so eintönig sind werden entlang
der Küste etliche Ausflugsziele
angeboten
für viele Norwegen Reisende ein
Highlight der Besuch einer
Schlittenhunde fahren
rund 140 Hunde leben hier früher waren
Hundeschlitten die einzige Möglichkeit
im Winter größere Strecken zurückzulegen
heute ziehen die Tiere vor allem
Touristen durch die Winterlandschaft ein
echtes Erlebnis für Familie Koal die
kennen das ja umzugehen
viele mit Hunde also von daher
eigentlich selber gar keine Angst
streicheln ja mitfahren nein Livia und
DAX sind noch zu jung für eine Tour auf
dem Hundeschlitten die Familie macht
sich stattdessen auf Entdeckungstour
hinter einer Holztür finden Sie ein
riesiges
Iglo wo crazy das so etwas existiert
eigentlich ne also das ist alles so hell
sind dass wir da drin schlafen kann kann
ich mir gar nicht so vorstellen
im Inneren ist ein Hotel hier ist alles
aus Eis Wände Decken Böden auf eisbetten
liegen dicke Fälle wer in einem der
zwölf Zimmer übernachtet bekommt noch
einen Schlafsack dazu das soll warm
genug für die Nacht sein
[Musik]
die Welt aus Eis fasziniert auch hier
und Dominik
Pipi machen muss
wie gesagt mit Kindern
aber die Kinder werden ja auch größer
und vielleicht kommen sie dann wieder
jetzt geht es aber erstmal weiter zum
norwegischen Nationaltier vier Rentiere
Leben auf dem Gelände sie zu sehen und
anfassen zu können ist für Dominik ein
unerwarteter Höhepunkt der Reise
ich habe immer früher nur gedacht das
gibt's den in den Kinderbüchern oder
Kindern sagen Rentiere jetzt sieht man
die wirklich mal live ja so das erste
Mal dass wir
würden auch hier und Dominik mit ihren
Kindern gerne länger bleiben doch sie
müssen zurück an Bord
man sehr unter Zeitdruck sehr sehr unter
Zeitdruck also wir hatten glaube ich
noch zwei Stunden da bleiben können
jetzt müssen wir wieder zurück zum
Schiff
die Rickert hat das Ziel der Reise fast
erreicht nach 6 Tagen auf sie wird das
Schiff morgen in Kirkenes einlaufen
an Bord hat expeditionsleiterin Svenja
Nordmann nach 12 Stunden endlich
Feierabend
die Kabinen der Besatzung liegen auf
Deck 2 wie jedes Crew Mitglied hat
Svenja eine Kabine für sich alleine
viel Platz gibt es hier aber nicht ein
Brief ihrer vierjährigen Tochter ist das
einzig persönliche in der zehn
Quadratmeter großen Kabine
es fühlt sich ein bisschen an als gelb
ist keine andere Welt als dieses Schiff
und alles was wir außerhalb des Schiffes
beobachten können aber das macht
ziemlich einfach es ist nur immer die
Übergangsphase die schwer ist oder
letzte Tag zu Hause der erste Tag an
Bord da passiert immer so eine mentale
Umstellung
drei Wochen dauert ihr Dienst auf dem
Schiff von zu Hause hat sich Svenja ihr
Cello mitgebracht als Zeitvertreib und
Erinnerung an Mann und Tochter
meine Tochter ist ja begeistert von
Einschlafmusik also ich spiele ja
meistens abends was vor und dann ruft
sie aus dem Schlafzimmer immer welches
Lied war das Mama und irgendwann fragt
sie nicht weil dann weiß ich es hat
funktioniert
[Musik]
es ist die letzte Nacht an Bord viele
schlafen schon als sie von einer
Durchsage geweckt werden ich lag schon
im Bett bin ganz ungeschminkt und jetzt
haben wir gerade die Benachrichtigung
bekommen dass die Nordlichter zu sehen
sind und jetzt sind alle ganz schnell
nach draußen laufen und vielleicht nicht
aufgeregt auf den wörtlich war am
Nachthimmel leuchtet die Aurora Borealis
in einem magischen Grün auf diesen
Moment haben alle an Bord gewartet
[Musik]
Größe
eindrucksvoll das lässt einen kleinen
wirken und
ja dankbar
wir fallen gerade irgendwie auch keine
Worte mehr ein weil ich das irgendwie so
schön finde
und man ist so weit weg auch von zu
Hause irgendwie und von dem ganzen von
dem ganzen Alltag sondern
darf irgendwie so ein
speziellen Moment erleben der irgendwie
nicht so richtig mit den anderen Dingen
zu tun
dieser Moment ist so wichtig für Fotos
[Musik]
sondern diese Erfahrung
so deutlich sind Nordlichter selten zu
sehen sprachlos
wahnsinn das auf jeden Fall meinem Leben
mal sehen zu dürfen
[Musik]
in immer neuen Formen tanzen die
Polarlichter über den Nachthimmel fast
eine Stunde lang sind sie zu sehen
[Musik]
am nächsten Morgen endet die Reise in
Kirkenes dem letzten Hafen der Route er
liegt nur wenige Kilometer von der
finnisch-russischen Grenze entfernt
sechs Tage und rund
2.500 km auf See liegen hinter den
Passagieren für viele endet die Reise
hier Familie hoal will aber mit dem
Schiff später wieder zurück nach Bergen
fahren auch wenn ihre Reisekasse schon
unerwartet leer ist
das hat auffällt ist halt das alles halt
sehr sehr teuer ist also da muss man
auch auf jeden Fall nachgucken gerade
mit Kindern ist relativ schwierig dann
alles unter einem Hut zu kriegen was man
ausgeht was man kauft
von Land und Leuten ist die Familie aber
begeistert ja Norwegen auf jeden Fall
aber dann gerne mit dem Camper oder so
auch Henni und Cedric wollen mehr
Norwegen erleben und bleiben an Bord es
ist ein bisschen das Gefühl von so ein
bisschen so Speeddating also man kommt
irgendwo an und man hat so eine
begrenzte Zeit die man irgendwie
verbringen kann und dann muss man schon
wieder weiter und man will irgendwie
noch viel mehr kennenlernen aber das ist
natürlich dann immer nicht so möglich
jetzt stehen noch einige coole Sachen an
ähm wir sind ja auch ähm auch noch in
einigen Städten in denen wir davor noch
nicht waren da freue ich mich auch total
drauf das Abenteuer auf den hortigroten
geht weiter auf der Fahrt zurück nach
Bergen werden Handy Cedric und die
anderen Passagiere noch viele Eindrücke
sammeln können bei Tag und in der Nacht
es war so Spaß ich möchte gerne jetzt
nicht auf
hören